before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
you know given the fact that I'm a
doctor who fan I guess having too many
thoughts on what's currently going on
with Doctor Who is a good problem to
have but you know
I would like to actually get some other
stuff done
[Music]
all right so this is a little bit of a
follow-up to the video
from two days ago oh good grief I used
to do a video a day like a couple years
ago
but I also didn't do them at the Quality
I currently do them so having now done
this is kind of breaking me a little bit
but anyways I talked about Disney
getting involved with the distribution
of Doctor Who now there's a couple of
things that I want to follow up on that
with some things that I just didn't
mention or didn't bring up either
because I didn't think of them or I kind
of realized a little bit after and
additionally I want to tackle something
that I just kind of completely glossed
over in terms of things that I didn't
get to in that video
it's worth pointing out that while the
actual announcements we have had so far
that indicate that Disney plus will
start carrying Doctor Who in every
territory other than the UK and Ireland
they have not in the announcements said
that that includes the back catalog now
despite that I did say it would include
the back catalog and I stand by that
even though they have not explicitly
stated it stated that because frankly
there is way less value in only new
episodes of Doctor Who I mean when HBO
Max announced that they were going to be
carrying Doctor Who their big push was
about we have new episodes but they also
got the back catalog of modern era
Doctor Who and to be clear I am talking
about modern era because I don't expect
Disney plus to start carrying classic
um they might I'd be surprised but I
would be stunned if they did not get the
bad catalog of modern era Doctor Who
there just isn't that much value in it
without it so that I assume is happening
although many people point out in the
comments technically that is not
confirmed but I cannot imagine that's
not the case next up I was a little bit
blase about it coming off of HBO Max
um I think I failed to note that it was
also going to be coming off BBC America
now one can debate whether that's a good
thing or a bad thing given that BBC
America would run it with ads and you
know maybe it wasn't the best way to
watch it in the first place but I came
at it in terms of my general attitude of
it's going to Disney plus okay but I
came at that from the perspective of an
American and also someone who already
has Disney plus Now in America modern
era Doctor Who has always been on paid
channels whether it be cable channels
that you had to pay for as part of a
cable package like sci-fi actually was
briefly on I think Disney XD for hot
minute hot minute and then later on on
BBC America or then on to HBO Max One
Way or Another modern era of Doctor Who
in America we've always had to pay for
it now some classic stuff got aired for
free on PBS but that was like back in
the 80s but that's not the case
everywhere this actually is kind of a
big impact on Australian fans of Doctor
Who the channel ABC no relation to the
ABC Network in America that's owned by
Disney but their ABC channel that has
always carried Doctor Who and that is a
free public broadcast channel and
they're now losing that ability to see
it at no additional cost for some other
service and that's never happened in
that country and that really sucks for
those fans Australia might not be the
only country where that's the case but
that's the one I've seen it pointed out
explicitly so those are some things that
I just flat out failed to mention
next is the thing that I didn't really
entertain but I'm now going to and that
is does Disney have any creative input
and if so what might that look like well
in terms of that first thing my gut
instinct initially on reading anything
about this deal was no they don't this
is a distribution deal a distribution
deal is not creative input it doesn't
get you involved in the production
that's not what that is however there
was a write-up in the Daily Telegraph
that seems to indicate otherwise now
it's been picked up by a few other
outlets since then all seeming to stem
from the telegraph
before I get too far into this let me
say up front
if I actually trust this reporting from
the telegraph for a couple reasons one I
actually have very little respect for it
as a paper overall but even setting that
aside while they do have some quotes
from Charlotte Moore the chief content
officer at the BBC in relation to that
deal
the article then spins off into a whole
bunch of things that it says as
definitively as things directly quoted
from her but without any Associated
quotes so honestly just looking at a
piece of Journalism it seems like they
made a lot of assumptions and published
them as facts but even if even if this
Telegraph article is not something that
should be trusted and turns out to be BS
I think enough people are concerned
about Disney possibly having input that
I think it's worth at least talking
about and exploring the possibility of
what that might look like because there
is one aspect that I kind of failed to
note that is pretty unique to this
Disney has never put something onto
Disney plus that they didn't wholly own
this entire deal is actually very new
for them like Disney has acquired a lot
they bought Pixar they bought lucasfilm
they bought Marvel they bought most of
fox and that forms the basis of what
they have available on that service and
it's a lot of stuff that's why they have
a lot of things on there but it's not
like with Netflix or even a fair amount
of stuff that's on something like HBO
Max where it's licensed material that
could theoretically be taken off once
the licensing agreement expires Disney
plus hasn't hosted that kind of content
before so it is interesting that it's
stepping a bit outside of what Disney
normally hosts there and that
that may indicate some desire to either
have more control or possibly looking
down the line to try and acquire the
property I don't think I'm gonna go down
that rabbit hole because that would
probably require the privatization of
the BBC first which is not out of the
question it's something that uh the Tory
party that's the conservative party
there certain members of it certainly
have been pushing for for quite some
time but until that step happens first
the idea of selling off Doctor Who isn't
really something that's on the table so
that is several steps down the
hypothetical uh trail and I just don't
really want to go any further down that
that having all been said what the
telegraph reported that again I can't
back up completely but what they are
saying is that Disney does not have any
kind of final say
um instead because they are contributing
towards the production budget that they
are expecting to have some degree of
creative input even though core creative
choices will be made by Russell today
Davis and he and bad wolf will have
final creative say that could parse if
Disney is directly contributing now like
in general it doing the distribution
gives money in but it just gives money
to the IP holder so like they're paying
the BBC for the rights to distribute
this all over the place that money
doesn't have to fund directly into
Doctor Who itself the BBC can use that
for whatever they want but if
um Disney is doing any kind of direct
production financial assistance that
gives them if not direct creative input
at the very least leverage and even if
it's not direct they could still
potentially leverage that even if uh the
BBC is funneling that money elsewhere
into the organization Disney going you
know what maybe this is going in a
Direction Where We don't want to renew
the contract after this that's a lot of
money that the BBC would be missing out
on and it allows them to leverage some
influence if they choose to now whether
or not we should expect Disney to do
that is a bit of a Minefield topic
because it kind of depends on who you
ask there's certainly lots of uh the
anti-woke outrage Merchants out there
who will tell you that Disney very much
imposes a specific uh Vision on all
kinds of stuff but the Practical matter
is that hasn't really been borne out not
on a large scale because the thing is
and like I'm gonna make comparisons to
things that Disney has acquired outright
because like I said I don't have a uh a
precedent for this kind of deal so I'm
gonna make comparisons to times that
Disney did buy stuff out right again
that doesn't mean I think they have or
will bought Doctor Who outright but
that's just the best comparison
comparison I can make generally what
Disney has been doing
is they have gotten hold of these
various companies and done some of the
normal restructuring stuff or maybe a
point in a new head like in the case of
lucasfilm but Disney doesn't directly
step in on those operations very much
especially in the case of something like
Marvel Disney basically bought them and
said keep doing what you're doing you've
got our money now so you can do more but
do your own thing there's been very
little indication of Disney directly
exerting influence on something like
Marvel and even Star Wars the buck does
seem to stop with Kathleen Kennedy now
you can have your opinions on that but
if she is operating basically as the
final word on Star Wars related material
at least as far as the entertainment
output of it goes then Disney has a
greater entity isn't really interfering
or doing a lot of creative input what I
expect Disney probably does have input
on is things related to the amount of
stuff made I would not be shocked that
if completely left to their own devices
neither lucasfilm nor Marvel would be
producing as much as often as they
currently are that wouldn't shock me if
that's a some amount of pressure from
Disney but that's not creative control
that's pushing for more product which
can impact the creative thing but that's
not really what people mean when they
say creative control now that doesn't
mean that there's nothing to worry about
because we can look at some of the stuff
with say Pixar now Pixar since being
acquired has also largely been left as
its own entity to be handled its own way
that having been said some of the stuff
that
um people spoke up about when the whole
uh don't say gay bill that Disney uh
ended up getting roped into the
discussion of you can check out a video
I made at the time if you don't know
what went on there it's lengthy there
was a lot to go through but some of the
stuff that came out when people started
speaking up at that point was that
Disney he did specifically veto some of
the stuff that creators wanted to put in
these movies specifically in terms of
queer representation that the higher-ups
the people above the directors of
certain films made at Pixar said no you
can't have that in there so it's not
that Disney never exerts creative
control but it does seem to largely be
sort of more generalized no please don't
do that as opposed to you must do this
now that still guides the shape of
something that is influence but there is
a difference between we demand that you
do this and please don't do that and
there is a there is a difference it's
not completely just a arbitrary
distinction because when you have been
cut off from doing certain stuff yes
that is a restriction that is that is uh
someone coming in and restricting your
creativity but it does leave basically
whatever else is left so as long as they
aren't doing a jillion restrictions that
leads you down this narrow field they
still got a lot of freedom in what you
can do on the other hand if you are
being told okay we expect this this this
and this then you're not giving options
with maybe a couple of uh paths locked
off to you they're just saying this
that's the path you take walk that path
and that doesn't really rhyme with how
Disney has been handling most of its IP
that it's been outright acquiring so I
can't imagine that any influence it
would have over Doctor Who would be any
greater since it's not outright
acquiring it now what the BBC may or may
not want to happen to do what it thinks
will please Disney that's where things
get a little bit muddled and a little
bit gray and it's where like yeah
maybe but that's the kind of thing
that's really hard to parse and nail
down and again I expect some people will
I I expect some people will flatly yell
that Disney is responsible for any and
all creative decisions that they
personally don't like
but all of that will be at best
unprovable and I would also say a pretty
big stretch and it's also worth pointing
out that while this is a new move for
Disney it's not a complete completely
new move for the BBC they have partnered
on Doctor Who before back in 1996 when
they partnered with Fox to produce the
TV movie that gave us Paul McGann as the
doctor that was intended to serve as a
backdoor pilot for a co-production with
Fox It ultimately did not pan out and
didn't end up happening because the
movie didn't perform well enough but
this is not an entirely new thing on the
BBC's part in terms of doing some kind
of partnering partnering that does
include creative input again assuming
that there is any creative input which
uh given the source that seems to be the
cause of all this speculation I'm again
kind of dubious about
but I still wanted to explore the
possibility what might that look like
well
overall I'd say if anything
it might be more likely to push the idea
of spin-offs and additional material
which we already had Sony now owning bad
wolf Productions who probably would also
want to push the idea of spin-offs and
additional material because that creates
more work for bad wolf Productions to do
so
I I would say if anything is going to be
the outcrop of this it's making uh is
making new spin-offs
um much much more likely and there's
been some reporting that RTD already has
an interest in doing so
if he does I just hope he doesn't jump
onto it immediately just just get
just just get the main show like on
solid footing first please uh we have we
had a we had a tumultuous era let's get
our feet under us before we start doing
a bajillion spin-offs
um so if that happens that would be
something that I would say probably has
some appeal to Disney because while not
reported I would imagine that this
distribution deal probably includes any
spin-offs that may or may not happen
so I think that's about all I've got
um I don't super trust this particular
article because of the source but I do
think that it was worth exploring the
notion of what that might look like
because if it's not the case now maybe
it'll be the case in the future
and it's just one of those times I don't
often indulge what-ifs I don't often
indulge if this is true let's talk about
what that means but
I guess I've been on a roll with Doctor
Who content this week already I thought
I'd get this stuff out of my brain so I
can maybe focus and do something else
ah
what do you think about what I've talked
about what do you think about my
assessment uh whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon is what pays
the bills around here so if you are able
to contribute any amount it does get you
Perks at every support tier and it helps
me out immensely but even if he can't
like share subscribe do help me out and
uh that is always of great assistance as
well but what I really want you to
remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
all right time to thank my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
lafolla Tarak the theme that goes joint
in the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emudelki Leo the Boyd toy lowly Becky
Sparks phenobilax the poodle Zach
Bookworm Tracy scrabot angry casperal
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla Gourley Brendan
Larose and TT thank you for your support
if you want to hear me try and say your
name while this little guy tries to chew
on my earrings well you can check out
the patreon or the support tears that
get you a shout out thanks so much you
are a pain in my butt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]